good morning believe nation today's
message is think about the things that
make your life better over to you
Tristan Walker I wake up every mood TV
go and one thing that I tell a lot of
folks who come to me and ask me these
questions right like how do I know which
company I want to work for or you know
how do I know what startup to create I
just tell them like look at their phones
right and you'd be amazed by even on
that like first page of your phone the
types of things that you use that other
people do not and you start to get a
very clear picture about like what's
your most passionate about and what you
have a view on that other people do not
right and the reason why that's so
important is because number one allows
you to identify things before anybody
else does which allows you to be
introduced to those companies at times
when no one else is trying to compete
for those same roles right and I've been
very very lucky to be able to find those
things as a result of that so you know
think about things you already use and
the things that actually make your life
better one of the best ways to design a
product to build a company is around
your own needs figure out what you need
what is missing in your life and then go
create that product one of my favorite
famous entrepreneurs who did that as LL
Bean who has the hunting and outdoor
equipment shoe store and product store
and his first product was a pair of
hunting shoes because he was a hunter
and he was out hunting and his feet
always got wet and he was frustrated
that no shoe really helped solve that
problem because he was tired of coming
back from hunting trips was soaked feet
so his first product was to create a
hunting shoe that didn't get wet and he
sold it to other hunters and then it up
building an empire I do this selfishly
in my business all the time I look at
the youtube channel i made the ents
wrestle series for me because i wanted
something in the morning to energize
myself to make me think bigger want to
do more than what i'm doing right now
to stretch my comfort zone a little bit
i created the top 10 series again for me
because i wanted to learn more about
these famous entrepreneurs it's
something that I love doing as long as
I've been an entrepreneur studying
success trying to model success trying
to take those strategies for working for
other people and put it to use in my
business there was no great resource
that I could find that put all these
rules together in a simple easy to
digest video format because i love
visuals and because i was so frustrated
i made it i was frustrated with music
right i wanted to have music that i
could listen to on a daily basis while
i'm at the office that would help me
with my productivity my creativity and
there wasn't a great mix i was put out
there for entrepreneurs and so i made
one these are all selfish projects that
I made for myself out of my own personal
need that I've then created something
that I share with you guys and because I
need it chances are there's a lot of
people like me who also knew the two
Jason who's behind the camera came in
today talking about a project where he
wanted to make a video for Sam Smith he
wanted to make a video unofficial music
video for a Sam Smith song that he loved
he watched them he want he listened to
the song there was no official music
video so he wants to go and create one
and now he's trying to go out and
recruit helpers if you're interested in
helping out leave in the comments below
that you want to be part of Jason's Sam
Smith video but that's how it starts
right like you see a need you want this
thing to be created it's not out there
in the world so you are going to will it
into existence that's what being an
entrepreneur is all about and so if
you're trying to find that next
opportunity for you look at what's
missing in your life look at what you
wish existed already and then go out and
create it believe so my question the day
today is I want to know what product or
service you've created or have an idea
to create around the need that you have
leave it in the comments below I'm going
to join in the sky
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presso i work this
spray so keep me go